celui-ci go on se retrouve pour une
nouvelle interview face cachée des
candidats et des candidates à l'élection
présidentielle et aujourd'hui je reçois
nathalie arthaud la candidate du parti
lutte ouvrière un parti classé à
l'extrême gauche alors nathalie arthaud
à 52 ans elle est enseignante mais aussi
donc engagé en politique depuis ses 18
ans dans son parti actuel lutte ouvrière
c'est la troisième candidature de
nathalie arthaud à l'élection
présidentielle après 2012 où elle avait
obtenu 0 56% des voix et 2017 où elle
avait obtenu 0
64% des voix et j'en parlais dans la
vidéo de décryptage de son programme
elle porte une revendication majeure
c'est la sortie du capitalisme alors
dans l'interview face cachée je vous le
rappelle nathalie arthaud fait face à un
écran géant sur lequel défilent des
émaux j à plusieurs reprises pendant
l'interview elle va appuyer sur le
buzzer pour que la route s'arrête sur un
emoji dont la face cachée va révéler
différents éléments qui seront à chaque
fois le point de départ de questions de
fond sur son programme et sur sa vision
de la france alors n'hésitez pas à vous
abonner à cette chaîne youtube pour ne
pas rater les interviews suivante et je
vous laisse avec la vidéo bonjour
nathalie arthaud bonjour merci beaucoup
d'avoir accepté mon invitation avec
plaisir est ce que les règles sont
claires dans les grandes lignes sur ce
we
visage on va voir à l'usagé on peut
commencer du coustou les directement du
coup appuyé sur le buzzer et on va voir
parce que s'arrête pour cette première
question
c'est un des mots j vidéo on va regarder
ensemble une vidéo qui va être diffusé
sur cet écran géant et on en parle du
coup juste après pour parler simple et
ou candidate à l'élection présidentielle
pour le gagner je ne suis pas candidate
pour être président de la république ce
si sûr alors ma choisi d'être un court
extrait courte vidéo un passage à qui
date de 2010 est au micro de rfi
aujourd'hui cinq ans plus tard est ce
que vous dites toujours la même chose et
si oui pourquoi du coup cette
candidature à l'élection présidentielle
oui je dis toujours la même chose je
j'explique en fait que j'aspire à bien
plus que m'asseoir dans le fauteuil du
président de la république parce que je
pense qu'il faut changer tout cette
société qu'il faut la renverser je pense
qu'il faut la changer de fond en comble
je suis communiste je suis
révolutionnaire et j'appelle dans cette
élection à le dire parce que je pense
que dans celle dans une élection eh bien
on doit pouvoir s'exprimer donc
l'occasion de porter un message de
verser une apporter une vision et puis
se rassembler de se rassembler de
montrer que ceux qui n'acceptent pas ces
inégalités cette société qui marche sur
la tête avec de l'argent incroyable mais
vrai un pool et puis yeux la misère la
plus extrême à l'autre et bien sont pas
seuls sont pas isolés peuvent se
raccrocher se rallier à un parti qui
existe qui a cette perspective là et
vous venez de le dire vous vous
définissez comme communiste
révolutionnaire par ailleurs vous dites
que vous ne valez pas à cette élection
forcément pour la gagner comment est ce
que vous souhaitez sortir du coup du
capitalisme de votre côté ah je suis
convaincu ça se fera par une explosion
sociale par des millions de femmes et
d'hommes qui se révolte qui se révoltent
et qui se politise et qui décident de
prendre leur sort en main qui décident
de réinventer justement la société par
en bas qui décide de prendre même les
décisions de ne plus laisser commandes
et donc il y a eu des exemples
d'insurrection de révolution dans
l'histoire on à paris on a connu la
commune de paris mais pour nous c'est
des moments très très important où les
révoltés décide de ceux de se gouverner
eux mêmes en fait est le schéma
capitaliste on le connaît pas ce qu'on
la france ouvre en course et des choses
qui sont connus à la question du
communisme on la prend aussi à notamment
par le biais de l'histoire être
communiste aujourd'hui en 2022 qu'est ce
que ça veut dire pour vous alors il ya
une chose qu'on apprend pas tellement
trop les programmes d'histoire c'est que
ce qui s'est passé en union soviétique
et la transformation de la révolution en
dictature stalinienne a été combattu par
un courant qui était le courant
trotskiste qui a tout fait pour que
cette révolution elle continue qu'elle
s'étende parce que dans un seul pays il
pensait que ça ne pouvait qu être
étouffée et puis finalement donné lieu à
cette caricature qui a été ensuite le
stalinisme donc c'est le courant
trotskiste qui qui qui qui a combattu et
qui pour nous a relevé 7 ce drapeau de
l'idéal communiste et nous nous en
revendique on sait ce qui fait que nous
sommes trotskiste et pas
voilà et pour nous ce qui s'est passé en
union soviétique c'était une caricature
de ce que pourrait être une véritable
société communiste qui pour nous doit
forcément être basée sur sur la
démocratie on va passer du coup à la
question suivante je relance la roue et
je voulais s'arrêter quand vous le
souhaitez
on va voir ce que pense tu arrêtes c'est
les mots j graphique ce qu'on va voir
c'est un graphique une stat ou autre on
va la découvrir ensemble et ensuite on
va pouvoir en discuter c'est en
l'occurrence une statistique issue d'un
rapport d'oxfam l'omg oxfam en 2020 qui
explique que lé 26 milliardaire les plus
riches ont autant d'argent que la moitié
de l'humanité la plus pauvre alors les
méthodes de calcul d'oxfam sont souvent
débattu et remise en cause - pas rentrer
dans les détails des méthodes de calcul
d'oxfam ce que c'est pas le sujet ici le
sujet donc c'est la question des
inégalités qui existent aujourd'hui dans
le monde question assez simple pour
commencer qu'est ce qu'on met en place
concrètement qu'est ce qu'on pourrait
mettre en place concrètement pour lutter
contre moi je pense que c'est le système
lui-même qu'il est créé qui les
fabriquent le système capitaliste qui
fabrique ces inégalités il les fabrique
au travers de l'exploitation donc si on
veut fermer le robinet il faut supprimer
l'exploitation de l'homme par l'homme
voilà donc il faut
il faut renverser la propriété privée
capitaliste et il faut exproprier la
grande bourgeoisie des entreprises
considérer que ces multinationales des
grandes entreprises nous appartiennent à
tous collectivement qu'elles sont le
fruit du travail de générations de
salariés de nous mêmes d'ailleurs et
qu'elle devrait être des propriétés
collectives et que ces dividendes
devraient au contraire servir revenir à
l'ensemble de la population comment
est-ce que ça peut se mettre en place du
coup très concrètement à l'échelle ce
que tu quand vous parlez faveur de leur
évolution de centaines de millions de
personnes mais à l'échelle de la france
par exemple comment ça pourrait se
mettre en place quels seraient les
mesures à mettre en place pour parvenir
à cela alors bon si la question c'est
comment on peut se déclencher une
explosion sociale ça moi je n'ai pas la
recette parce que si je l'avais health
l'aurait utilisé depuis fort longtemps
mais je pense que la société elle est
tellement dure et elle est tellement
elle génère tellement de frustration
tellement d'injustices et d'oppressions
que forcément il y aura des révoltes on
l'a vu avec les gilet jaune on voit même
avec aujourd'hui cette contestation
le convoi de la liberté qui voit là a
cessé il ya une contestation sociale moi
je suis convaincu que tôt ou tard elle
va s'exprimer et elle va entraîner dans
son sillage des millions de femmes et
d'hommes et moi ce que je pense qu'il
faut qu'ils aient une politique
d'ailleurs qu'ils sachent où aller et où
aller ce qu'il faut aller contester la
propriété privée des grands groupes il
faut à s'inviter dans les entreprises
donc si je comprends bien quand on vous
pose la question vous répondez soit par
cette question par cette réponse de mr
ça va passer par une révolte et une
reprise en main de l'état par les
travailleurs etc c'est tellement de
l'état les grandes entreprises aussi des
entreprises aussi et concrètement c'est
à dire que vous ne l'envisagé pas de
mesures il y en a d'autres candidats à
gauche par exemple qui parle de
certaines mesures de redistribution des
richesses ou quoi qui qui se voient
appliquer en tant que président de la
république ou présidente de la
république de votre côté ce que c'est
des mesures que vous avez en tête de
votre côté que vous aimeriez à mettre en
place mais moi je suis convaincu que
healy à 7,7 nécessité la de renverser la
société capitaliste et la transformer de
fond en comble de la transformer en
sociétés collectives le communisme mais
en attendant cette explosion sociale
majeure il y à des combats à mener des
combats petits et grands et il y à des
combats qui sont à notre portée avec ces
mois dans les objectifs
concrets à court terme que je mets en
avant c'est des objectifs d'augmentation
de salaire pour moi le smic et doit être
à 2000 euros ça doit être un des
objectifs de 1000 euros nets de nos
combats 2000 euros nets et puis je pense
aussi que on doit avoir cette
préoccupation de dire il faut qu'il y
ait zéro chômeur il faut qu'il y ait
zéro chômeur parce que le chômage c'est
un drame pour tous ceux qui qui sont
condamnés à l'inactivité c'est un drame
bien sûr matériel mais aussi morale donc
et comment
zéro chômeur c'est une question qui
revient souvent dans la campagne à la
question de la réduction du temps de
travail par exemple oui parce que c'est
une quelque chose dont vous êtes
favorable de réduire le temps travaille
pour alors cet objectif de meilleure
répartition au sein de la société où il
faut répartir le travail entre tous et
ça en fait c'est super c'est ce qu'on
fait dans une famille dans une famille
quand ya du travail à faire un
déménagement ou alors un grand repas une
grande fête france réparti le travail
toi tu t'occupes de ça toi tu t'occupes
de ça et c est chacun prend sa part il
faudrait raisonner comme ça à l'échelle
de la société donc ont réparti le
travail existant entre tout le tout les
bras disponibles
donc ça veut dire qu'il faut créer des
emplois partout où ils sont nécessaires
dans les hôpitaux dans les ehpad dans
l'éducation mais beaucoup de temps
beaucoup d'entreprises aussi est ce que
répondent certains à cela parce qu'on le
voit qu'un action pour la réduction du
temps de travail surtout à gauche
d'autres sont pour l'allongement de la
durée du temps de travail à droite
surtout ce qu'ils répondent c'est qu'il
ya une notion de compétitivité entre les
pays que si on réduit le temps de
travail on va être moins compétitifs par
rapport à d'autres états que donc les
entreprises vont délocaliser dans
d'autres pays m6 me critiquer qui
revient très souvent quand on parle de
réduction du temps de travail qu'est ce
que vous répondez à cette critique c'est
vrai c'est vrai et c'est une réalité que
le système capitaliste fonctionne avec
des lois des la loi du profit
la loi de la concurrence de la loi de
l'offre et la demande cette compris
entre judokas pas les mêmes règles de la
compétitivité est effectivement en effet
donc c'est la raison pour laquelle moi
je dis que les objectifs de répartir le
travail entre tous pour que zéro chômeur
ou d'augmenter les salaires jusqu'à et
un smic à 2000 euros on va pouvoir
véritablement conduire ses combats et
est même être victorieux que si on a
cette conscience qu' il faudra peut-être
weir en faire renverser ces lois et peut
aller jusqu'à peut-être changer
complètement l'ordre social parce que
sinon on subit toujours cette pression
mais oui mais ça fonctionne pas dans le
cadre du capitalisme écoutez si cette
société capitaliste ne permet pas ce
qu'il apporte qui la font vivre qui la
font fonctionner d'avoir un salaire
décent à chaque être être humain un
d'avoir pour gagner sa vie et bien il
faut la changer voilà mais qu'on parte
de nos besoins qu'on parte de nos
intérêts et puis effectivement qu'on
avance sur nos revendications sur nos
besoins et qu'on change la société si
nécessaire on parle du coup ici
d'inégalités par ailleurs on a vous avez
parlé tout à l'heure de deux grands
bourgeois c'est un autre terme que vous
avez utilisé une question qu'on peut se
poser c'est c'est quoi être riche selon
vous nathalie arthaud selon une étude
qui a été publiée par l'observatoire des
inégalités est considérée comme riche
toute personne dont le revenu mensuel
après impôt est supérieure à trois mille
quatre cent soixante dix euros est ce
que vous êtes d'accord avec ça ou pas
alors d'abord moi je me pose je pose pas
la question en termes de riches parce
que je pense que la richesse elle est
très relative ce ça me fait penser à une
discussion que j'ai eue dans la rue avec
un jeune justement qu'il y avait
toujours galéré ou rsa et pour lui avoir
un smic touché un smic 1 pour la
première fois de sa vie c'était john
c'était devenir riche et oui et je le
voyais pas ce qu'il avait il avait les
yeux qui brillaient donc la richesse
c'est très relatifs c'est quelque chose
de très relatif est ce que je moi parce
que je pointe c'est pas tant la richesse
que le pouvoir que confère les capitaux
d'exploiter les autres et donc de
profiter du travail des autres et même
de vivre du travail des autres moi quand
je parle de grande bourgeoisie je parle
de ceux qui ne font rien de leurs dix
doigts mais qui s'enrichissent de simple
fait que leurs capitaux sont placés ici
sont placés là et font des petits seins
voilà donc c'est ça que je conteste mois
et ce que je conteste c'est pas
tellement leur richesse d'ailleurs entre
parenthèses c'est le pouvoir qu'ils ont
le pouvoir qu'ils ont sur la société le
pouvoir qu'ils ont sur l'ensemble des
travailleurs et le pouvoir qu'ils ont de
décider de caisse qui sera produit ou
comment qu'est ce qu'on fait avec la
planète etc ils prennent des décisions
qui nous engage tous qui engage
l'humanité et la planète et ça moi je ne
comprends pas comment on accepte qu'une
qu'une poignée parce qu'ils sont parce
qu'ils ont des milliards de milliards
puisque oms a confisqué la véritable
démocratie pour vous la richesse n'est
pas qu'une question d'argent dans un
compte en banque c'est aussi le un
pouvoir que ça octroie très bien il a
des inégalités que ça et bien c'est ça
entraîne aussi on va passer à la
question suivante on va du coup relancer
la roue je vous laisse l'arrêté qu'on
fait et
on va s'arrêter sur un chronomètre c'est
en l'occurrence un exercice assez
particulier je vous posais une suite des
questions en une minute l'idée tente de
répondre par oui ou par non à chacune de
ces questions pourquoi ça l'idée c'est
de mieux comprendre votre programme est
votre vision de la france sur certains
sujets assez près s'il dure on va on va
essayer de faire le mieux possible et on
va commencer avec la première question
c'est parti faustin accueillir sans
condition tous les réfugiés en france
oui l'union de la gauche est ce que vous
y croyez non faut-il sortir du nucléaire
je dis non trail faut-il rembourser tous
les soins sans exception oui philippe
poutou pourrait-il être votre premier
ministre du pouvoir des travailleurs oui
revenu universel est ce une bonne idée
non faut-il supprimer le loto oui la
coupe du monde de football au qatar
faut-il la boycotter oui
parce que vous pourriez être ami avec
quelqu'un de droite
non
faut-il légaliser le cannabis
oui la france doit-elle rester dans
l'union européenne
les états unis socialistes d'europe et
du monde le changer en tout cas pas les
ai pas lues norvège telle qu'on la
connaît dernière petite question faut-il
abc le droit de vote à 16 ans oui on a
pu en faire un certain nombre je suis
conscient que c'est quand même un
maniaque et même quelques-unes je
conçois que ça frustrant parfois deux
oui très rapidement à certaines m'ont a
pu voir comme ça certains aspects de
votre vision de la france plus
précisément sur l'union européenne juste
là dessus c'est intéressant vous avez
hésité puis par les états unis
socialistes n'ont d'état d'état des
états unis d'europe socialiste qu'est ce
que ça veut dire concrètement c'est à
dire un modèle comme ce que vous
imaginez ce que ça veut dire que d'abord
aujourd'hui je suis consciente que
l'union européenne c'est une
construction qui va bien justement pour
port pour le business et c'est
d'ailleurs comme ça que l'union
européenne a été construite et ce n'est
pas du tout pour répondre aux besoins et
aux intérêts des peuples et des
populations donc c'est pas mon europe 1
et mais par contre je pense qu' il
faudrait moi ma conviction profonde j'ai
dit que j'étais communiste c'est que
faudrait que l'ensemble du monde du
travail des travailleurs la l'écrasante
par la population prenne le pouvoir elle
même et ça ça ce sera un pouvoir
socialiste de ce pouvoir socialiste et
faudrait qu'il soit international et
doit être internationaliste moi je vois
bien qu'il ya pas de solution à
l'échelle d'un seul pays aujourd'hui et
vous êtes à paris la crise écologique la
crise économique y a pas de solution à
l'échelle nationale qu'il faut être
internationaliste ils ont d'ailleurs que
vous êtes favorable à un élargissement
sans celle de l'union européenne dans
l'idée ce que cette même idée d'aller
justement avoir un palais européenne
telle qu'on la connaît aujourd'hui mais
l'union européenne avec une union autour
de valeurs communes moi ma première
chose on doit sortir du capitalisme on
doit fonder une société collective avec
les travailleurs au pouvoir et là oui
bien sûr qu'il faudra abattre les
frontières il faudra abattre les
frontières moi je me dis que dans dont
je n'ai pas un millénaire par exemple
quand les chercheurs et les historiens
se pencheront sur
sur les années 2000 2020 il se dire mais
qu'est ce que c'était que c'est trés
l'a1 qui courent et qui correspondent à
rien ni à une montagne à une rivière ni
1 où il fallait qu'ils étaient des
obstacles pour les la circulation enfin
voila il mais pour moi les frontières
voilà elles sont
ces c'est comment dire c'est un héritage
mais mais mais empoisonnée qui devrait
être enfin qu'il faut supprimer quoi on
va passer à la question suivante on
relance j'ai coularou je vous laisse à
pied quand vous le souhaitez sur le
désert
et mais sur une lemozy citation une
bulle de discussion en fait derrière
cette bulle on va découvrir une prose
une proposition pardon d'un ou d'une
candidate à l'élection présidentielle
je vous laisse là lire ce que vous
arrivez à savoir déjà qui a proposé une
telle chose aux primaires j'augmenterai
de deux heures par semaine
l'enseignement du français d'une heure
celui des mathématiques pour arriver à
50% du temps de classe consacrez-vous
français et 25% en mathématiques beau ça
ressemble aussi à ce pourait du blanc
caire ça pourrait donc du maquereau ce
pourrait être cette influence est
candidate à l'élection présidentielle
donc c'est valérie pécresse est
effectivement vallée pécresse donc
candidate de droite mots comme pas trop
quoi en fait candidate du parti les
républicains vous qui est enseignante
qu'est ce que vous pensez de cette
mesure d'augmenter alors de français et
de maths sachant que là on parle de
l'école primaire non mais moi aux
primaires
j'augmenterais surtout le nombre
d'enseignants et je travaillerai par
petits groupes voilà ça c'est la
priorité et après à partir de là eh bien
oui on peut si on peut imaginer faire
plein de choses et aux primaires
j'apprendrai aussi les langues
étrangères
parce que parce que le cerveau des
enfants peu
peu emmagasiné énormément de choses mais
il faut se donner les moyens et ça passe
par des moyens humains en fait et ce qui
me révolte ce qui me révolte c'est ce
gâchis c'est à dire on demande à tous
les enfants de de progresser au même
rythme c'est marche ou crève en fait
c'est marche ou crève on ne regarde pas
les différences on ne regarde pas les
problèmes individuels d'où il arrive
quelles sont leurs obstacles à on leur
demande de franchir les mêmes voilà les
mêmes obstacles obstacles en même temps
moi je trouve sympa voilà je trouve ça
me révolte je suis enseignante et et je
pense que c'est un gâchis immenses et on
devrait commencer au primaire
effectivement vraiment en 3e en petits
groupes et là on pourrait s'intéresser à
chaque à chaque enfant et on pourrait
lui donner envie envie envie de
redescendre il sait quelque chose car en
l'occurrence c'était cabinet macron a
essayé de mettre en place durant son
quinquennat notamment dans des zones est
les quartiers défavorisés en permettant
d'avoir moins d'élèves par classe pour
vous du coup ce n'est pas suffisant ce
qui a été dit parce que ils l'ont fait
et y compris en prenant sur des
enseignants qui s'occupait d'un réseau
d' aide aux enfants en difficulté et
puis il faut le généraliser et à tous
les niveaux et à tous les niveaux pas
seulement cp pas seulement en enseignant
il faut il faut aller sur tous les
niveaux et encore une fois il y a des
des classes des quartiers où il faut
peut-être encore plus de moyens mais il
faut les mettre l'avenir l'avenir
ccc elle est incarnée par par par par
cette jeunesse donc oui un gouvernement
qui aurait à coeur un de représenter les
intérêts de la population il mettrait le
paquet là-dessus je pensais que le
métier d'enseignant est encore
attractifs aujourd'hui vous puisque vous
le voyez en tant qu'enseignante même
plus généralement le métier d'enseignant
est ce qu'il vous semble attractif
encore aujourd'hui pour pour des jeunes
pas eu c'est évident que vu
vu les salaires et les niveaux d'étude
demandé c'est évident qu'on peut partir
dans le privé avoir un salaire le double
je pense pas pour professeur de
mathématiques c'est pas un hasard qu'il
en manque cruellement un des profs de
maths et massy parce que effectivement
on démarre à 1700 euros 1800 enfin bon
c'est complètement dingue et puis les
pistes vrai que les conditions dans
lesquelles on travaille ne font pas
envie voilà vous savez moi je crois
qu'il ya un parallèle à faire entre ce
qui se passe dans l'enseignement dans
l'éducation et les hôpitaux et les
hôpitaux publics et moi je me des fois
je me dis que ce que ressentent les
personnels les hôpitaux des ehpad par
exemple dont certains disent que il
fonde la maltraitance c'est parfois le
sentiment que j'ai vis-à-vis d'un
certain nombre de jeunes et d'élèves de
faire de la maltraitance pourquoi parce
que j'ai pas le temps j'ai pas le temps
de m'intéresser à 10 ans sont comment ça
va comment ça va pas surtout comment ça
va pas et puis d accompagner c'est une
question de moyens pas forcément d'heure
deux heures de cours mais surtout de
moyens ça passe par contacts humains et
puis je crois quand même qu'avec le
confinement le et
l'école à la maison rouge je crois que
tout le monde l'a bien l'a bien senti ça
passe par un échange humain ça n'a pas
aidé effectivement on va passer à la
question suivante je vous laisse appuyez
sur le buzzer
c'est une carte les mots j car c'est
donc derrière sa face cachée on va
découvrir une carte ensemble on va
pouvoir la découvrir alors est-ce que
vous avez une idée c'est pas facile dit
comme ça donne enfin vu comme ça c'est
même assez assez difficile de ce que
représente ce que pourrait représenter
cette carte qu'on va pouvoir en discuter
c'est ca ça rien que la france oui
apparemment il ya un lien très net avec
la france la grand voile
qu'est ce que ça pourrait être selon
vous vous êtes sur la bonne voie on sait
effectivement on voit c'est la finlande
ouais je peux vous donner le
nucléaire je sais pas cessé leurs
agneaux d'intervention française assez
lent l'udc lancent les lieux et les
autres afficheurs on affichera la
légende de montage dans laquelle marie
que les forces françaises sont bien sûr
y ployer base et donc vous voyez que
n'at on a beaucoup pourquoi est-ce qu'on
voit cette carte est bien parce que
nathalie arthaud si vous êtes élu il n'y
aurait à priori plus ces zones de
couleurs sur la carte pourquoi alors si
les travailleurs étaient au pouvoir
parce que c'est ça mon ma perspective
c'est effectivement un gouvernement
du monde du travail des travers de la
population elle même donc il faut
non pas forcément moi présidente et pas
forcément avec des ministres d'ailleurs
ça sera tout autre chose mais évidemment
si les travailleurs étaient au pouvoir
eh bien il aurait plus ses intérêts en
afrique qui correspondent en fait au
business des bolloré des bouillides des
orane haut
voilà il n'aurait plus ses intérêts il
aurait plus
y voit là et iloilo il ressentirait pas
besoin d'être présents y compris
militairement pour assurer la sécurité
de l'exploitation et du pillage des
richesses est ce que c'est vraiment
toujours le cas et dans toutes les
situations ça que vous aviez dit il me
semble que dans votre programme que les
guerres menées à l'étranger sont menées
pour le profit et jamais pour l'intérêt
des peuples est ce que seront toujours
le cas si on prend le cas de l'opération
barkan du coup en afrique au sahel où la
france est engagée
qu'il y ait des intérêts économiques
c'est assez c'est assez évident mais il
ya d'autres intérêts que sont aussi
mises en avant ils sont vus comme des
arguments principaux notamment
l'objectif affiché de lutter contre les
djihadistes présents dans la région qui
pose des vraies questions de sécurité
dans la région est ce que c'est vraiment
une question uniquement de économique
dans ces situations là c'est une
question oui uniquement économiques et
même dans le cas de l'opération marque
anne par exemple absolument et c'est
vrai que le terrorisme est devenu
nouveau prétexte en fait un nouveau
prétexte pour
conserver sa zone d'influencé
mais regardez ce qui se passe au mali
aujourd'hui comment la population elle
même elle le vit est ce que c'est cette
intervention française leeza leeza idée
affronter ces bandes lac irak est qui
qui prennent en otage qui détruisent des
villages non c'est non seulement ça ne
les a pas aidés est-ce que ça les a
aidés aussi à mieux vivre parce que le
ces bandes terroristes elles sont aussi
le produit du dénuement le plus que le
plus complet est ce que la france quand
elle est intervenu là est-ce qu'elle a
aidé à vous déploiement de
l'infrastructure au mieux-vivre de la
population et non vous savez c'est pas
nouveau ses interventions françaises en
afrique 1 à la même colonisés et même la
colonisation elle était menée au nom de
la civilisation et non en fait la france
a été une grande puissance qui a
effectivement piller piller les
richesses dont qui continuent à lutter
donc ce n'est son nez large de la
question de l'opération barkan mêmes
d'ailleurs au delà de la question de la
france puisque on comprend bien que vous
aussi un sujet plus global et
philosophique ce n'est pas le bon terme
et de vision sur ce genre de choses oui
si on a un pays en difficulté face à des
forces djihadistes par exemple en
afrique ou dans un autre pays
qu'elle est est ce que c'est à dire
concrètement les autres états n'ont pas
aller intervenir et aider y compris si
le gouvernement le demande c'est ces
pays là moi je pense que
le les puissances impérialistes comme la
france elles sont
en grande partie la cause la cause du
problème la cause du problème et donc
c'est sûrement pas elles qui sont à même
de d'apporter la solution voilà encore
une fois si ces états sont aussi d'élite
et si cette misère est ce encore là
c'est le c'est le fruit de la politique
en fait des puissances impérialistes et
voilà ils sont responsables elles sont
responsables et donc non la première des
choses c'est qu'on n'arrête justement
avec ce pillage avec cette confiscation
parce que vous savez c'est aussi des des
zones qui sont riches qui sont riches en
riche en matière première riche en
matières premières uranium le club mais
jamais jamais la population n'en profite
jamais la pression d'un profit donc il
faudrait commencer par là on va passer à
la question suivante je voulais
s'appuyer sur le buzzer
cette fois ci on est sur un cadeau et
pas n'importe lequel en l'occurrence
derrière ça me fait rire ce credo
s'afficher en fait une vidéo mais c'est
une vidéo d'un autre candidat à
l'élection présidentielle qui vous a
posé une question on vous laisse du coup
découvrir le candidat écoutait du coup
sa question et après je vous laisserai
évidemment y répondre cher alain péligat
aux beaux jours
d'avoir j'ai parrainé à deux reprises à
l'atelier jeux où j'ai vu lors de la
dernière campagne
on va beaucoup parler mais je sais
combien vous êtes passionné par votre
métier et vous avez tenu à aller
jusqu'où ce dernier jours d'enseignement
avec vos élèves j'imagine votre émotion
au moment de les quitter et je voulais
savoir ce que vous avez ressenti au fond
de vous même
qu'est ce que voulait lui répondre
j'ai donc là je suis en congé électorale
parce que si je fais la campagne tous
les jours c'est quoi en congé électorale
au passage pour ceux qui se vouent est
enseignante mais en même temps campagne
présidentielle c'est à dire que vous
avez des congés donc elles sont
autorisées du fait de la participation à
une campagne présidentielle voilà c'est
ça c'est assez ça c'est vrai pour les
différentes campagnes en fait enfin pour
toutes les élections quand on est
candidat on peut avoir selon l'élection
certain nombre de jours de congés de
congé voilà donc eh bien je
oui je je je leur ai expliqué dai
d'abord quand je leur ai dit au revoir
je rêvais d'une classe de seconde et une
classe de première cette année donc je
leur ai expliqué ce que j'allais faire
parce que je ne me voyais pas partir en
leur disant voilà
comme une malpropre donc je leur ai
expliqué ce que j allais faire et puis
je leur ai dit au 11 avril parce que oui
je pense que je ne sois pas élu et je
retournerais les voir donc voilà j'ai
jeu oui c'est avec un peu d'émotion soit
il a raison avec un peu d'émotion je
lisais je leur ai mais je leur ai dit au
revoir en même temps plus vous
retrouverez c'est qu'ils sont faits sauf
en cas d'élection qui s'est maintenue
voire les trouveront en avril en aller
danser ça on va passer à la question
suivante même chose je vous laisse le
pied sur le sur le buzzer
et c'est un des on va jouer à un jeu
mais pas un jeu de plateau n'est rien
concrètement on va reprendre une
mécanique de jeu que certains jeunes
connaissent peut-être c'est le tu
préfères alors on dira vous préférez
plutôt ce sera ce sera mieux
concrètement ça consiste à devoir faire
un choix entre deux propositions
volontairement parfois un peu
particulière mais l'idée c'est de
répondre après a le plus possible entre
deux de ces options vous allez voir je
vous montrais le premier il y en a deux
comme ça
le premier c est ce que vous préférez un
dîner avec joe biden donc le président
américain ou un dîner avec elle aux
masques entrepreneurs d r space x votre
caisse qui serait le plus intéressant
selon vous dis non discutez de dire
c'est volontaire mais c'est si
volontiers ce que vous souhaiteriez
discutées à l'occasion d'un dîner ou
autre chose derrière ward a été bonne
mais c'est peut-être pourquoi qu'est ce
qu'il me semble eh bien il vaut mieux
discuter avec dieu qui avec ses apôtres
pour vous et le mosquées dieu dans un
système oui comme aujourd'hui très clair
très clairement bah oui vous savez
quel'on musk sa fortune elle a dépassé
les 300 milliards c'est un des hommes
les plus riches au monde juste derrière
jeff bezos ce
qu'est ce que pour derrière avec deux
soirs 12h02 sans vie deux cents
200 milliards à temps sur mon compte en
milliards là donc voilà bah oui je
préfère dîner avec dieu qu'avec ses avec
parce que parce que ça veut dire
concrètement pour bien comprendre quand
vous dites ça c'est que un quelqu'un
combien de masques c'est l'une des
personnes les plus riches au monde qui a
un pouvoir biens durables c'est ce que
vous dites c'est que ce ver abl cette
masse d'argent dont on parle est
d'ailleurs tout à l'heure oui amen un
pouvoir qui parfois selon vous dépasse
le pouvoir des politiques c'est ça c'est
sûr j'en suis convaincu voilà c'est sûr
parce qu'en fait lui avec avec tesla et
avec tous ces investissements et puis
son ca à sa domination financière sur un
grand nombre en fait d'autres
multinationales parce que c'est son
désintérêt des capitaux qui se croisent
qui s'entrelacent en réalité il a des
représentants sans doute dans un grand
nombre de conseils d'administration qui
programme qui programme la leur lors
leur prochain plan c'était de dire voilà
vous voyez là dans une élection à la
présidentielle on a des programmes
politiques on est censé se
déterminer en fonction des programmes
politiques mais il ya d'autres
programmes qui sont en préparation qui
les gens la société qui justement vont
diriger qui vont s'appliquer dans les
grandes multinationales et on n'a pas de
prise et c'est ça le problème de notre
société capitalise une pas avoir de
prise sur notre système productif alors
même que sans nous ils ne pourraient pas
fonctionner très rapidement si l'on pose
la même question sur dans le cas de la
france par exemple est ce que ça veut
dire que vous considérez que une
personnalité comme bernard arnault donc
à la tête d'un groupe comme lvmh a plus
de pouvoir que le président de
république par exemple
oui oui tout à fait bernard arnault
draiss a peut être bolloré ça peut être
bouygues ça peut être peugeot bien sur
arcelormittal moi je me souviens par
exemple vous savez quand hollande a
essayé de mener un bras de fer avec
mittal pour que florent je ne ferme pas
je me souviens que donc mittal le
propriétaire un i les indiens et
peut-être il a plusieurs plusieurs
nuances possibles il est allé
directement l'elysée un pour dire
écoutez voilà en france il ya vingt
mille salariés qui dépendent de moi vous
n'allez pas vous n'allez pas me gêner
vous allez rien faire qui me qui me gêne
donc vous vous calmez surtout ça et puis
finalement c'est montebourg qui est
partie vraiment le poids selon vos 2 c
mais bien semestriel de ces groupes
rapport aux politiques fois que nicolas
hulot a dénoncé quand il a démissionné
de son poste quelques trous de
l'économie voilà parce que est en fait
il n'a pas utilisé les mêmes mots que
moi mais il parle de système malgré tout
alors moi c'est de l'écologie
effectivement moi je mets un nom c'est
le système capitaliste lui parle de
lobby moi je parle de deux grandes pour
choisi je parle de classe capitaliste
parce qu'il faut nommer les choses pour
comprendre un petit peu la situation et
pour pouvoir trouver des solutions on va
passer à une autre une deuxième session
pardon sur le même principe là c'est
facile alors voilà la marseillaise est
ce que vous préférez pour la
marseillaise tout mon à connell
international peut-être un peu moins je
voulais well expliquer rapidement qu'est
ce que c'est l'international alors
l'international s'est effectivement
l'hymne des travailleurs en lutte et
pour nous c'est
notre drapeau c'est notre drapeau
l'international en plus c'est vraiment
l'idée que tous les travailleurs de tous
les pays
constitueront un un seul et même
quand qui changera qui transformera la
société qui prendra le pouvoir mais
alors pour important selon look la
marseillaise ah mais c'est c'est
véritablement ça en fait c'est un
programme c'est le programme et c'est le
perspective pour tous ceux qui sont
révoltés lisez les paroles de
l'international lisez les paroles
fantastique
on va passer à la dernière question je
vous laisse appuyer ce sera ce sera la
dernière
c'est un mémo jc drapeau français c'est
pas le drapeau jaune quand ces drapeaux
français pour cette fois vous allez
découvrir en fait des phrases qui va
falloir compléter l'idée temps de
reprendre une formule de france hollande
qui avait prononcé en 2012 face à
nicolas sarkozy le mois président alors
j'ai cru comprendre au fil de la
discussion que de votre côté sera
peut-être pas un mois président ou un
nous présidents ou un nous à la tête de
la france ou de même pas de la france de
plus largement mais je vous laisse
compléter du coup le lire et compléter
ses phrases là en une phrase assure fois
pour mieux comprendre votre vision de la
société vos objectifs en soi et on va
voir tout de suite avec le premier
exemple nous au pouvoir les jeunes quand
est-ce qu'on pourrait compléter cette
phrase en une phrase les jeunes pourront
investir toute leur passion
à fond au suivant nos pouvoirs les
riches les riches seront mis hors d'état
de nuire
nos pouvoirs notre ennemi sera sera les
préjugés
hérite les préjugés et les comportements
barbares hérité de la vieille société
capitaliste la finance du coup
l'économie et les préjugés l'intolérance
et la misogynie
le racisme etc nous pouv oir notre
première mesure sera alors sera la
répartition du travail entre tous pour
baisser considérablement
le temps de travail de tous pour
travailler
- pour travailler
de trois heures par jour à et bien sûr
faire en sorte que ce travail donne
l'accès à tous au même on aime richesse
de trois heures par jour vous avez dit
de trois heures par jour tout n est que
ça fait par semaine en semaine de 15
heures c'est ça c'est ça que vous
envisagez en termes de réductions du
temps de travail et c'est beaucoup moins
que à gauche que certains proposent
quand il parle de 32 heures lieu des 35
heures actuelles oui imaginez mais parce
que vous savez en soi sans après 68 il y
avait eu toute une discussion il ya vu
des statisticiens qui s'était penchée
sur le problème et qui avait fait le
calcul comment à quel niveau de
d'horaires on devrait travailler si on
travaillait tous s'il y avait zéro
chômeur si on enlevait les doublons
s'ils ont planifié la société pour qui
est pas tous eu cette gabegie ces
gaspillages ces croisements enfin voilà
tout ce que tout ce qui va aujourd'hui
avec ce marché concurrentiel la loi de
l'offre et la demande et il était arrivé
au résultat de travailler deux heures
par jour et on en fait un bouquin
d'ailleurs travailler deux heures par
jour c'est accessible chez les
bouquinistes donc si c'était possible
dans les années 70
aujourd'hui voilà aujourd'hui et il en
reste un il me semble nous au pouvoir la
france sera une région du monde parce
que tout le monde aura à coeur de dire
que
à coeur de dire mon pays c'est la terre
nathalie arthaud merci beaucoup d'avoir
accepté cette interview je précise au
passage que comme pour tous les autres
candidats à l'élection présidentielle
cette vidéo est doublé aussi d'une vidéo
de décryptage de votre programme il est
temps de mieux connaître là aussi votre
vision de la france au-delà de cette
interview merci encore pour votre pour
votre temps et du coup c'est la fin de
cette vidéo j'espère qu'elle vous aura
plu évidemment n'hésitez pas à vous
abonner à cette chaîne youtube chaud
mais ça vous a intéressé pour ne pas
rater du coup les vidéos qui arrivent
les autres interviews de candidats ou
décryptage de programmes en description
comme à chaque fois je vous mets des
liens pour en savoir plus poussée entre
vous et on se dit du coup a très vite
encore merci à nathalie retour merci